بقذائف تحتوي على اليورانيوم المنظم
قرارهم بريطانيه واجه انتقادات دوليه
وتهديدات روسيه لكن ما هي قذائف
اليورانيوم المنظم او المستنفذ وهل هي
اسلحه ذات مكونات نوويه كما قال الرئيس
الروسي
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه دافعت عن هذا
القرار قائله بان هذه القنابل او قنابل
ذخائر خارقه للدروع تحتوي على يورانيوم
منظم وهو مكون معتاد لا علاقه له بالاسلحه
النوويه ومستخدم منذ عقود كما هو معلوم
بحسبها تصنيع هيكل هذه القنابل يعتمد على
عناصر اليورانيوم الثقيل والذي يعد اكثر
كثافه من الرصاص وبالتالي قوه اكبر اثناء
الاصطدام ونار كثيفه اثناء عمليه الاختراق
هذه الذخائر مشاهدينا بغايه الفاعليه
لتدمير دبابات ومدرعات حديثه وهي معدله
للاستخدام بواسطه دبابات كما نشاهد هنا
التي تعتزم طبعا لندن تزويد اكياس بها
ايضا الا ان القذائف اليورانيوم المنظمه
عدم وجود حظر دولي عليها فهي تنطوي على
مخاطر تهدد صحه العسكريين الذين
يستخدمونها في مناطق النزاع ومناطق القصف
الامم المتحده تصنف اليورانيوم المنظم
كمعد ثقيل سام كيميائي واشعاعي باعتباره
المنتج الثانوي الرئيسي المتبقي بعد عمليه
تخصيب اليورانيوم نفس خصائص
الكيميائيه لكن خصائص اشعاعيه اقل فهنا
وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه وصفت قرار
البريطاني لنقل قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم
الى اوكرانيا بتكرار لسيناريو اليوغوسلافي
اي حرب كوسوفو عام
1969 حينها القي ما يقارب 15 طنا من
اليورانيوم المستنفذ خلال ثلاثه اشهر ما
تسبب بتلويث الانهار وارتفاع معدل الاصابه
بالاورام الخبيثه كاس رفضات الدم والرئه
وايضا تلف الكلى
[موسيقى]